die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis einen guten Abend wünsche ich
Ihnen den Sport hat Norbert Lehmann für
Sie einen schönen guten Abend und wir
blicken auf den neuesten Entwicklungen
aus Russland
ein Absturz und viele Fragen Putin
bestätigt indirekt den Tod von
söldnerchef brigogin und kondoliert
alles übrige bleibt Spekulation auch ob
der Absturz ein Racheakt Putins war
aus fünf werden elf die brig-staaten
nehmen neue Mitglieder auf sie wollen
ein Gegengewicht zur Macht des Westens
sein
und die Altlasten von Fukushima
japan.leichtradio aktives Kühlwasser ins
Meer denn die Tanks an Land sind zum
Bersten voll
[Musik]
kann der Chef Putin hat eben indirekt
den Tod von Söldner Chef pragori
bestätigt er kontrollierte der Familie
man werde sehen was sie am Mittler
herausfinden sagte Putin weiter das
könne dauern pregorian soll an Bord
eines Flugzeuges gewesen sein das
gestern abgestürzt ist was bisher über
den Absturz bekannt ist fast Nina
kuscheln zusammen
es ist 18 Uhr Ortszeit als die kleine
Passagiermaschine fast senkrecht
abstürzt wenige Minuten nach dem Start
die embreier Legacy eigentlich noch im
Steigflug gerade auf 8.500 Metern Höhe
das Flugzeug ist von Moskau auf dem Weg
nach St Petersburg als es in der Region
quer am Boden zerschellt ich hörte eine
Explosion oder eine Art Knall
normalerweise gibt es bei einer
Explosion am Boden ein Echo aber es war
nur ein Knall ich schaute nach oben und
sah weißen Rauch ein flügelflug in die
Einrichtung weg und der Rumpf in die
andere
ungewöhnlich schnell wird die
Passagierliste veröffentlicht unter den
Namen auch der von seltener Chef gehen
auch sein Stellvertreter die metri utkin
soll mit an Bord gewesen sein
als Abschlussmöglichkeiten für mich
etwas technisches oder ein
pilotenausfall vollkommen aus es bleibt
nur ein gewaltsam dass Ereignis am in um
das Flugzeug und da gibt es entweder die
Möglichkeit einer Bombe an Bord oder
eben und darauf deutet viele sind in
Abschluss durch eine Flugaffäre geht
mittlerweile wurden alle Leichen
geborgen forensische Untersuchungen
sollen nun ermitteln wer die Opfer
tatsächlich sind
für viele ist pregorians tod untrennbar
mit Wladimir Putin verbunden genau wie
sein Aufstieg zu soweit Zeiten war
pregorjin ein Krimineller saß neun
Jahren einem Straflager
1990 die Wende ein Hotdog stand wurde
zum Grundstein für ein Gastronomie
Imperium lange galt er als Putins Koch
pregorian bediente putinswünsche auch
mit einer Privatarmee bis er dann den
kremischer herausforderte Sebastian ehm
vor der Zentrale der Wagner Söldner in
St Petersburg legen die Menschen heute
rote Nelken ab eine in Russland seit
sowjetischen Zeiten weit verbreitete
Ehrung für gefallene Soldaten heute
gedenken Sie hier jewgen für sie ist er
ein Held
es fühlt sich an als würde man einen
Vater verlieren er war alles für uns
denn alle haben immer darauf gewartet
was er sagen wird
als Chef der Söldnertruppe Wagner trat
Gregorian besonders brutal und
martialisch auf vor allem in der Ukraine
spätestens seit seinem Arsch auf Moskau
war er weltbekannt sein Ziel so sagt er
die russische Militärführung Absetzen
der mutmaßliche Putschversuch für Putin
Verrat doch dann gewährte er prigorcin
Straffreiheit
vor wenigen Wochen wirkte es dann so als
seibrigogin zurück auf der politischen
Bühne Auftritt auf dem Russland Afrika
Forum und vor drei Tagen dann ein Video
in gewohnter Pose angeblich in Afrika
Wagner führt aufklärungs- und
Suchaktionen durch und macht Russland
auf allen Kontinenten noch größer und
Afrika noch freier für viele beobachte
es dennoch klar Putin hat pregorian den
Aufstand nie verziehen der Präsident
meldet sich dann am frühen Abend über
den Verrat kein Wort stattdessen Lob der
bregorian als talentierten Geschäftsmann
was diesen Flugzeugabsturz betrifft
möchte ich zunächst den Familien aller
Verstorbenen mein aufrichtiges Beileid
aussprechen es ist immer eine Tragödie
hätte hätte
nun sollen Ermittlungen über den Absturz
Folgen unklar ist wie lange diese dauern
werden am Tag danach sind in Moskau
viele Fragen offen
egal in der Chef der wagnergruppe soll
also tot sein Armin Körper in Moskau was
wird jetzt mit der seltener Gruppe
ich denke ich denke Russland wird mit
selten dann weiter zusammenarbeiten die
Frage ist nur mit welchen die
wagnergruppe hat vor allem in Afrika
harte Interessen Russlands hart
durchgesetzt da geht es zum Beispiel um
Rohstoffe die das Land gerade jetzt
unbedingt braucht wir hören das ist oder
wir wissen dass es hier im Land dutzende
solcher Privatarmeen gibt die Frage ist
jetzt ob die Wagner sollten da in andere
Systeme integriert werden oder ob jemand
anderes den Job übernimmt klar ist
Russland kann darauf nicht verzichten
und wir können davon ausgehen dass es
ein Nachfolger an Plan B für große gibt
des Namen man hinter mir im Kreml heute
Abend ganz bestimmt auch kennt
danke schön Armin Körper
welche Auswirkungen der Tod von Wagner
Chef pregorien auf Putins Krieg gegen
die Ukraine hat erklärt Russland Experte
Nico lange bei ZDF heute live um 19:30
Uhr in der ZDF heute App und auf unseren
Social Media Kanälen
die Ukraine machte klar sie haben nichts
mit dem mutmaßlichen Tod pregorians zu
tun und auch das meldet Kiew eine
ukrainische Einheit sei in der Nacht auf
die Russisch besetzte Krim gelangt im
Westen der Halbinsel habe man Russlands
Militär geschwächt Moskau behauptet man
habe den Angriff abgewehrt
unterdessen feiern die Ukrainerinnen und
Ukraine heute ihren 32
Unabhängigkeitstag das Datum fällt auch
auf den Kriegsbeginn vor genau
anderthalb Jahren
Präsident selenski appellierte an die
Einheit der Bevölkerung im Kampf gegen
die russischen Angreifer
und in der Ukraine ist für uns eine
brüll Anne Ukraine meldet also eine
Operation auf der Krim wie wird die von
der Bevölkerung wahrgenommen
ja die ukrainische Flagge auf der Krim
heute am ukrainischen Unabhängigkeitstag
das ist schon ein sehr starkes Symbol
ein Symbol auf das viele hier gehofft
haben die Gegenoffensive die läuft ja
eher schleppend es gibt hohe Verluste
auf der Krim die ist ja seit 2014 von
Russland besetzt und diese Operation
dort die wurde vom militärischen
Nachrichtendienst bestätigt da wurde
bekannt gegeben dass da Spezialkräfte
Marine Soldaten Wasserfahrzeuge im
Einsatz gewesen sein und hier heißt es
auch solche spezialoperationen die
würden in Zukunft weitergehen das wären
dann Einsätze weit hinter den
feindlichen Linien sozusagen Nadelstiche
denn Präsident selenski hat ja immer
wieder gesagt der Krieg hat auf der Krim
begonnen er wird dort auch zu Ende gehen
das Ziel ist ganz klar die Rückeroberung
der Krim
danke schön alle wohl
beim Gipfel der bricks starten in
Südafrika haben vor allem China und
Russland darauf gedrängt ihre Gruppe
soll größer und damit noch wichtiger
werden heute erhielten sechs Staaten
eine offizielle Einladung
aus bricks also Brasilien Russland
Indien China und Südafrika Salat 2024
bricks plus werden dann zusätzlich mit
Argentinien Ägypten
Äthiopien Saudi Arabien den Vereinigten
Arabischen Emiraten und Iran in den
bricks plus Ländern leben rund 47% der
Weltbevölkerung und sie tragen knapp 37%
zur globalen Wirtschaft bei Verena
Garrett berichtet
er hat auf sich warten lassen als der
südafrikanische Präsident mit fast einer
Stunde Verspätung aufs Podium kommt hat
er eine Ankündigung im Gepäck die den
besten aufhorchen lassen wird die
brix-staaten bekommen Zuwachs 6 neue
Mitglieder
wir haben eine Einigung über die
Leitprinzipien Standards Kriterien und
Verfahren des
brix-erweiterungsprozesses erzielt wir
sind uns über die erste Phase der
Expansion einig weitere Phasen werden
folgen
konsensors und der fest face of this
expansion process
Einigkeit genau damit glänzte die
brex-gruppe bislang eben nicht die
Handelsinteressen enorm unterschiedlich
jetzt haben sie in Johannesburg einen
gemeinsamen Nenner gefunden größer
besser unabhängiger besonders China
drängte darauf damit der Block an
globalem Gewicht gewinnt
die neuen Mitglieder bedeuten eine neue
Ausgangslage für die Brix Zusammenarbeit
und verleihen unseren Kooperationen neue
Impulse
alle fünf bricks-staaten kritisieren die
internationale Machtverteilung die
Erweiterung lag in der Luft das ist eine
in dieser Größenordnung wird für viele
überraschend was sie konkret bedeutet
noch nicht absehbar
ich denke nicht dass sich dadurch die
Weltordnung per se verändert aber es
stärkt die Stimme des globalen Südens
und man muss sich mit den
Schlussfolgerungen befassen die sich
daraus ergeben
die brix-gruppe wird zu BRICS plus eine
leichte Zusammenarbeit wird es auch in
Zukunft nicht
gehen wir direkt zu Verena Garrett
Verena was bedeutet die Erweiterung der
bricks
ja die brix-staaten haben ein Ziel
erreicht sie wollten die Stimme des
globalen Südens stärken und sehen sich
als Gegenbild des Westens wenn jetzt
gleich sechs Länder dazukommen dann ist
es natürlich so dass ich bricks direkt
in der Größe verdoppelt und dann auch
geopolitisch und wirtschaftlich mehr
macht bekommt was man nicht vergessen
darf es ist eine heterogene Gruppe es
gibt unterschiedliche Handelsinteressen
große wirtschaftliche Unterschiede und
das jetzt schon schwer und das war
bisher schon schwer einen Konsens zu
finden und so wird es auch in Zukunft
wohl bleiben ab 2024 dann sind die neuen
Länder dabei sie gehören dann dazu und
Brix wird dann entschuldigt wird dann
nominiert dominiert werden von autokrath
autokratisch regierten Ländern und
Staaten und die Frage wird sein wie wird
der Westen darauf reagieren danke schön
in Japan hat eine umstritten Aktion
begonnen am 2011 havarierten
Atomkraftwerk Fukushima wird von heute
an Kühlwasser ins Meer geleitet
bislang wurde das verseuchte Wasser in
riesigen Tanks aufgefangen inzwischen
lagern auf dem Gelände mehr als 1,3
Millionen Tonnen um es abzuleiten hat
der Betreiber beim unbeschädigten
Reaktor 5 ein Tunnel durch den felsigen
Meeresboden Geburt dass das Wasser jetzt
in den Pazifik läuft halten viele für
falsch Elisabeth berichtet
seebrasse aus der Präfektur Fukushima
wer wird sie noch kaufen wollen fragt
sich supermarktinhaber Takashi nakacima
jetzt wo das aufbereitete verstrahlte
Kühlwasser ins Meer gepumpt wird
sie sagen es sei sicher aber es gibt
keine Untersuchung darüber was passiert
wenn das Kühlwasser jetzt 30 Jahre lang
ins Meer abgelassen wird
1,3 Milliarden Liter verstrahltes
Kühlwasser es läuft durch eine
Filteranlage ein radioaktives Element
kann dabei allerdings nicht entfernt
werden Tritium
der sorgen dafür dass die ablassung in
den Ozean sicher ist und den geltenden
Richtlinien entspricht und trotzdem
wütende Proteste am Vormittag in Tokio
und den Soul Südkorea China stoppte
heute die Einfuhr von Fisch und
Meerestieren aus Japan für Experten
besteht kein Grund dafür das dreht sich
um das abgeleitet werden soll es an
einer Konzentration vorhanden die um
einen Faktor 7 unter der Empfehlung der
Weltgesundheitsorganisation für
Trinkwasser liegt
das könnte man also wenn es kein
Salzwasser wäre gefahrlos trinken
Tritium Wasser in Flüsse oder Meere
abzuleiten ist eine gängige Praxis von
Kernkraftwerken weltweit was dennoch
fehlt sind Langzeitstudien so wird Tepco
noch viele Jahre um Vertrauen werden
müssen Japans Imageschaden ist groß
in Deutschland wird weiter diskutiert ob
industriebe die besonders viel Energie
brauchen Strom billiger bekommen sollen
jetzt hat sich die Fraktionsspitze der
SPD positioniert sie schlägt vor dem
Preis für bestimmte Unternehmen bei 5
Cent pro Kilowattstunde zu deckeln
zunächst fünf Jahre lang mit dem Vorstoß
soll auch Bundeskanzler Scholz überzeugt
werden der die Subvention mit Skepsis
betrachtet
immer mehr Menschen die auf Pflege
angewiesen sind hätten Schwierigkeiten
die Kosten dafür zu stemmen Angesicht zu
steigende Eigenanteile das beklagt ein
Bündnis aus Sozialverbänden und
Gewerkschaften es fordert eine Reform
der Pflegeversicherung alle Kosten für
die Pflege im Heim oder zu Hause sollten
übernommen werden Petra Otto mit einem
Beispielfall
helmut putschkun hat nicht schlecht
verdient bei der Berufsfeuerwehr für
drei Kinder hat es gereicht doch jetzt
fürs Pflegeheim ist seine Rente nicht
hoch genug
3.300 Euro Eigenanteil die Ersparnisse
schon weg seine Tochter hat jetzt
Sozialhilfe beantragt mein Vater dürfte
es nicht wissen er hat klipp und klar
gesagt wenn wir Sozialhilfe beantragen
müssen dann springt er vom Balkon Helmut
putschkun ist kein Einzelfall auch nicht
in der reichen Stadt Stuttgart wir
merken dass immer mehr schon einziehen
mit der Prämisse dass wir relativ
schnell Sozialhilfe beantragen müssen
laut einer repräsentativen Umfrage heute
in Berlin vorgestellt befürchten mehr
als 80 Prozent ein Pflegeheim nicht
finanzieren zu können eine ganz breite
Mehrheit der Bevölkerung über alle
Partei Grenzen hinweg will die
solidarische vollpflegeversicherung
deswegen unser Appell an die
Bundesregierung machen Sie eine Reform
hin zu einer vollpflegeversicherung eine
Reform die wirklich alle Menschen wollen
auch bei der ambulanten Versorgung ist
alles auf Kante genäht kaum Zeit zum
Reden und mehr Hilfe im Bad das kann
sich Frau Wirth schlicht nicht leisten
der Pflegesatz deckt das nicht wir
werden Sie täglich Unterstützung
brauchen zum Beispiel bei der
Körperpflege und das ganze morgens und
abends ist
müssen Sie schon eine sehr hohe Summe
selbst drauf handelt es nicht reicht es
reicht schon jetzt hinten und vorne
nicht und die Kosten für die Pflege die
werden erstmal weiter steigen
wer geht für die Republikaner ins Rennen
um das Weiße Haus bei der ersten
Fernsehdebatte lieferten sich die
Bewerberinnen und die Bewerber einen
Schlagabtausch allerdings nicht mit
dabei Donald Trump der ehemalige
US-Präsident hatte seine Teilnahme
abgesagt Benjamin Daniel bricht
er hatte die wohl schwierigste Aufgabe
des Abends Ron des Santes größter
parteikoneur gleich auf mit dem
Ex-Präsidenten doch nach zahlreichen
wahlkampf-
ich werde keine Truppen in die Ukraine
schicken dafür aber an unsere Südgrenze
dort bringen die Schmuggler Drogen wie
pentanyl ins Land es wird das Letzte
sein was sie tun wir werden alles
dagegen setzen und sie eiskalt töten
trumpe für water kommt vor allem bei
jungen Republikanern gut an er sieht die
USA in einer Identitätskrise
die Menschen sind auf Sinnsuche in einer
Zeit in der Familie Glauben Patriotismus
harte Arbeit nichts mehr zählen was wir
brauchen ist ein Neuanfang von oben um
klar zu machen das ist es was uns
Amerikaner ausmacht
Trump kam nicht und sprach stattdessen
mit dem ex-fox Moderator Tacker Karlson
der fragte ihn ob er Angst habe von
seinen politischen Gegnern umgebracht zu
werden
das sind wilde Tiere völlig kranke Leute
sie hassen unser Land schauen Sie sich
die Situation an unserer offenen Grenze
an schauen sie sich ihre Politik dazu an
und zu so vielen anderen Dingen es ist
so traurig mit anzusehen unsere Nation
ist im Moment sehr fragil
Trump wird das Bewerberfeld zur Zeit mit
mehr als 40 Punkten Abstand an die
Gerichtsprozesse scheinen ihm in den
Umfragen sogar noch zu helfen Experten
glauben aber dass sich das durchaus noch
ändern könnte
in Chile leiden die Menschen unter den
Folgen heftiger Regenfälle große Gebiete
des Landes sind überflutet in Santa Cruz
gleichen die Straßen Flüssen knapp 90
Prozent der Stadt stehen unter Wasser
noch immer sind viele Menschen von der
Außenwelt abgeschnitten und müssen
gerettet werden es kam auch zu
Erdrutschen nur 15 Meter von diesem
Apartmentkomplex sagte der hanger
jetzt kommen wir zum Sport zur WM in der
rhythmischen sportgymnastiker Valencia
Norbert der räumt ja eine junge Deutsche
gerade so die Goldmedaille gemacht
das junge Ausnahmetalent nachdem sie im
Juli bei den Final schon alle fünf
deutschen Meistertitel gewonnen hatte
holte sie gestern zum WM Auftakt gleich
zweimal Gold ja und da ist noch mehr
drin für die 16-jährige
wer innerhalb von 45 Minuten zwei
Goldmedaillen gewinnt begeistert auch
neutrale Fans zunächst entzückt daher
war Polo meef mit dem Reifen elegant ist
tätig einfach glanzvoll die Darbietung
der Enkelin eines deutschen Großvaters
im Alter von 12 Jahren war sie ohne ihre
Eltern von Westsibirien nach Deutschland
gezogen wie ein Popstar gefeiert wird
sie dann auch nach der Übung mit dem
Ball perfekt einstudiert in unzähligen
Trainingseinheiten beim TSV schmieden
vor den Toren Stuttgart zweimal Gold hat
sie schon es könnte noch mehr Medaillen
werden in Valencia
die FIFA hat gegen den spanischen
fußballpräsidenten Louis robalis ein
Disziplinarverfahren eingeleitet obiales
hatte bei der Siegerehrung am Sonntag
die spanischen fußballweltmeisterin
Jennifer ermoso unvermittelt auf dem
Mund geküsst die Spielerin twitterte
anschließend das hat mir nicht gefallen
große Empörung weltweit morgen
Sondersitzung des spanischen Verbandes
der THW Kiel gewinnt gestern Abend in
Düsseldorf den Handball Supercup Krimi
gegen die Rhein-Neckar Löwen nach der
regulären Spielzeit stets 33 zu 33
Entscheidung durch 7 Meter werfen
lindenkrone Andersen verwirrt für die
Löwen und danach trifft Erik Johansson
zum 37 zu 36 Kiel gewinnt zum vierten
Mal in Serie den Pokal
nach den deutschen Hockey Frauen stehen
jetzt auch die Männer im Halbfinale der
Heim durch den Sieg gestern gegen
Frankreich am Abend in Mönchengladbach
Halbzeitstand 1:1 dann brachte Lukas
windfeder sein Team direkt nach wieder
Anführung und in der 42 Minute
schließlich tief Prinz zum 4:1 Endstand
Deutschland trifft morgen im Halbfinale
auf England
[Applaus]
und die deutschen Frauen spielen gleich
um 20 Uhr im Finale gegen Belgien danke
schön und
wir bleiben gab es das erste aktuelle
Sportstudio mit der unverkennbaren
Melodie
entdecke
wie das Torwandschießen ob präzise
verwandelt bei Franz Beckenbauer kam
dabei ein Bierglas ins Spiel oder
übereifrig irgendwas trafen die Gäste
immer und wenn mal etwas baden ging dann
darf man sportlich 60 Jahre Stars und
Sternstunden wir sagen herzlichen
Glückwunsch
und mehr gibt es auch auf Sportstudio
punkt.de
der Deutsche Wetterdienst warnt aktuell
vor schweren Gewittern in Teilen
Baden-Württembergs und Bayerns die
meteorologen sprechen von einem
Wettersturz mehr gleich von Katja
horneffer das heute journal läuft an
diesem Abend um 21:40 mit Marietta
Slomka tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend jetzt ist es mit der
Hitzewelle vorbei schon heute kam von
Westen dichte Wolken heran und die
brachten am Nachmittag Gewittern mit der
Nordrhein-Westfalen in Rheinland-Pfalz
im Saarland und auch in
Baden-Württemberg das hat auch zur Folge
dass die Nächte nicht mehr so warm sind
wie die vergangenen heute Nacht sinken
die Werte auf 19 bis 16 Grad und
allenfalls hier in Thüringen oder auch
am Rhein bleibt es noch bei einer
tropischen Nacht mit 20 Grad oder 21
Grad Tiefsttemperatur dazu fällt zum
Teil kräftiger Regen es können auch
einzelne Gewitter dabei sein die
unwetterpotenzial haben die also mit
Starkregen und mit Sturmböen verbunden
sind am ehesten trocken bleibt die Nacht
hier in Nordosten und morgen ziehen dann
jede Menge Regenschauer und Gewitter von
Südwest nach Nordosten Weg sie müssen
nicht jeden treffen können aber
prinzipiell jeden treffen und können
auch Unwetter artig sein und dann
längsten trocken und freundlich bleibt
es wohl bis zum Abend im nördlichen
Schleswig-Holstein der Wind kommt aus
südwestlichen Richtung und an der
Nordsee liegen morgen die Temperaturen
bei 20 bis 22 Grad im Südosten geht's
noch mal bis 32 Grad drauf und dann
stürzen die Temperaturen ab am Montag
liegen sie nur noch bei 14 bis 22 Grad
guten Abend